amelita Chua lost her son Mark Wilson
when he was 19 years old in February
2001 he exposed bribery corruption and
extortion in his University's training
program for military Reserve officers
weeks later he was murdered the gruesome
images are still Vivid in amelita's
memory it was fished out from the pasig
river wrapped in carpet with pocket
wrapped in packaging tape a year after
Mark's death mandatory military training
for male college students under the
reserve officer's training Corps or ROTC
program was scrapped
but now president Ferdinand Marcos Jr
and his allies in Congress want it back
this time it'll be for all college
students male and female
it's not only enough that we
modernize our Armed Forces we also need
to make sure that we have enough boots
on the ground it's always been a
tradition that the source for reserviced
is from the ROTC in the face of China's
increasing assertiveness the Philippine
military has been beefing up its
defenses forging closer ties with the
United States and other allies but some
youth leaders want no part of it more
than 20 years ago male college students
in the Philippines marched and carried
out powerful drills on Open Fields like
this their strong support for the return
of mandatory military training in
campuses but critics question its value
then and now
during the final campaign event for the
election of student leaders at the
University of the Philippines all
candidates were against it this despite
the Assurance of politicians that the
ROTC bill has safeguards against abuses
these public officials tend to ignore
valid criticisms on the mandatory ROTC
program that's why we can't trust such
events board even though they say that
it will be created to reduce or
eliminate abuses
amelita says Mark loved being in the
ROTC program and she understands the
need for the country to be able to
respond more adequately to disasters or
an attack but she wants all the
perpetrators of her son's murder to be
brought to Justice and for others in the
country to learn from what happened to
him
only then she says can her family and
others affected by his death move on
one below Al Jazeera Manila